what do you think you know when when you
meet a girl say she passes some of these
flags here
how can you tell the difference between
lost the honeymoon phase and real
what are some markers oh yeah because
that's that's a good question
yeah if you want to see what a woman's
really made of in a in a relationship
watch how she handles uh difficulties in
your like let's say you get sick right
uh you get coveted or you know some like
really bad cold or flu this should take
care of you you know she makes you some
soup does she expose her immune system
to risk to be around you to look after
you sort of thing right because your
boys won't do it you know uh that's what
a good woman will do you know like if
you've got a good woman in your life
there's something going on with your
family maybe one of them will come sick
she offers to take care of them offers
to do things cook for them stuff like
that
um that's when you'll see what a woman's
really made of but that would be after
the honeymoon phase that would be yeah
that would be after the yeah that's
after the Where Do We Stand phase and
you've dated for a while like that's
what you should really show her true
colors but
um it's been said that women can act
uh or you date the representative for as
long as a year and a half maybe up to
two years but women have a difficult
time acting or being a representative of
something that they're not beyond that
so you know guys that rush into a
marriage in like three months or
something like that probably not the
best idea yeah
um because you're only going to see what
she's made of during difficult time like
when you do travel and her luggage gets
lost does she have a complete meltdown
and lose her at the attendant you
know the counter sort of thing or did
you say no problem we'll get it later
let's go to the store and get some stuff
all right
that I've heard that many times a
representative I just lost
I lost too bad like very expensive bags
of stuff what three four months ago and
the girl I was with is flipping out I'm
just like okay it happens what are you
gonna do you know what are you gonna do
but I'm very calm with things like that
well you know you know one thing Rich
too uh I can't say I have this problem
thank God but
um
you know there's women out there now and
this will probably get taken the wrong
way by someone that don't know how to
cook
at all
and it's either order out every day or
uh guys cooking or whatever it may be
but like I think that's a great thing a
woman who can cook
I love a woman with culinary skills
um I mean one of the reasons why I chose
my girlfriend was because she's a great
cook
um some people don't like that they
don't care they say oh I can cook for
myself or you get these guys are like
well I prefer cooking I'd rather cook
for her sort of thing it's like
okay fine look I don't care how you want
to structure your life but I value a
woman that that comes to my house with
bags or groceries and prepares a
delicious nutritious and healthy meal
for me like to me that's a woman like
that's the chick that I want to spend
more time with sort of thing
um so you know I guess you got to get
clear on your priorities I got another
friend of mine that likes cooking like
he like he absolutely loves meal prep
cooking the presentation like that's his
like that's his jam and he doesn't care
if women can cook right so everybody's
got their preferences but I think you
know traditionally speaking most guys
value to women that know how to cook
well going through all the stuff that
we're going through we're talking about
cooking we're talking about all this
different stuff I guess my question to
you is is there the the perfect woman
out there
everybody's going to have their own
version of the perfect woman I mean you
ask 20 guys you could get 20 different
answers there's there's soy boy beta
males out there that you know love Joe
Biden and wear like I love Joe Biden
t-shirts uh that would tell you I like
uh morbidly obese women with short
purple hair and Tattoos all over their
body right like like that's their ideal
woman that play video games and have an
only fan right like you're gonna get
different answers from from different
guys typically speaking guys like me the
guys that roll in my circles the guys
that are entrepreneurs the guys are
making bank that are cool to hang out
with that do fun stuff we've got very
similar tastes and I don't think that
that's a coincidence I think that that's
what men that are doing something with
their life generally gravitate towards
feminine women right strong masculine
virtuous men gravitate towards feminine
beauties that uh complement their lives
and are just you know fun and pleasant
to be around I guess what I'm saying is
for like for a woman for guys at role in
your in your uh group
well if let's say there's 10 there's a
checklist of ten I know you have 20
there but say 10. yeah are you gonna
look for every single one meaning will
they meet every single part of that
checklist or you might deal with nine
and okay that one's okay not to have on
there
yeah so I think you can have it all but
you can't have it all at the same time
with the same gal right you might get it
all within two or three girls sort of
thing like you know Becky ticks off nine
out of ten and then Rachel ticks off
like the other one for you sort of thing
like that's potentially possible but
I mean men and women have different
checklists don't they like when you ask
a woman what their checklist is it's
pretty long you know it's pretty
extensive especially when they sit down
with their committees
that's like holy like where are you
gonna find this guy guys like most guys
checklists are is just sexually
available
yeah that's it's not very complicated
for most guys now that was my checklist
when I was younger too now it's okay
that's not a big deal anymore I figured
that part out it's easy to you know
satiate that but you know is she a
compliment to my life you know can she
cook the ship culinary skills is she
Pleasant does she have a low to no Notch
count right uh you know she doesn't have
like a zoo in her house you ever date
these gals that have like 15 animals in
their house oh yeah you walk through the
front door and all you smell is urine
right like there's a lot of deal
breakers for a lot of guys so again like
for most guys it just boils down to is
she pretty and is she sexually available
we don't really care about their jobs I
don't care if a chick makes forty
thousand dollars a year or four hundred
thousand dollars a year in fact the girl
that makes four hundred thousand dollars
a year
she doesn't share her pot of gold with
me anyway it's not like she's gonna be
buying me because women don't do
that so like what difference does it
make she's probably gonna be more bossy
more disagreeable than the Forty
thousand dollar a year girl right so you
know a lot of these things are moving
targets like this is a big puzzle with a
hundred maybe some maybe it's 100 pieces
for some guys for other guys it might be
a thousand pieces it's just a big puzzle
with a bunch of different pieces and you
got to decide what's right for you I
don't know if you've been on it but if
you haven't been on it or you haven't
had a moment you should have uh Patrick
McDavid on uh value table uh we had him
on it and he this will always stick out
with me forever he said when I was
dating girls you know I was in Vegas
going out blah blah blah and he would
say look I like you but you're never
going to be the mother to my kids and if
you don't like that basically kick rocks
if he finds the woman that he likes that
he wants to marry before they marry they
want to go to a uh psychiat or therapist
so it's so he walks into the therapist
you know and they're paid you know okay
he's socio therapist how long have you
been married therapist says uh 30 years
Pat says what is what is the most
important thing that kept you guys you
know married for 30 years or what is the
most important thing or the your
favorite time of being married and the
therapist goes well we have dinner every
night at six o'clock Pacos here's your
200 and walks out the door right wife is
saying what did I do wrong and Pat is
like no nothing I'm never gonna be home
at 6 p.m I'm an entrepreneur I'm trying
to take over the world I'm never gonna
be home at 6 p.m
and I thought that was admirable and it
goes along with a lot that you say as
well that you just be up front you know
like I'm not going to be at home at six
you know I'm trying to do a lot of
things and if that's the kind of guy
you're looking for yeah yeah yeah and it
and it and it takes a special kind of a
woman to uh like bend the knee and yield
to a strong man's frame like that like
you know pbd is a you know he's a very
strong character and not all women
especially the party girls from Vegas
you know maybe the ones he was dating
before would be a good fit for him in a
long-term relationship right so the
again you know like what you're doing as
a guy in your 20s when you're in your
party you know time or even early 30s
you know hanging out going to Vegas
doing a b is a film Canada side and the
other thing 12 hours a night you start
meeting all these women and if you start
thinking about children you know sort of
thing or like you know am I gonna put
some babies in her then you want to find
the right kind of gal for that right and
I think one of the most in important
predictors is one does she enter your
frame and complement your life and two
is she pure you know like I don't want
to put babies in a woman that's been
with 50 guys this disgusting yeah right
like 50 other guys have been there like
you know when you think about that
there you know guys get repulsed by that
but women generally don't they're like
oh he's got some experience good yeah or
or or other women have chosen him good
right because women like pre-selection
too right like they want to be with guys
that other women like or or now or
nowadays the guy is like wow that was
her past and I have her now but to me to
me I agree with you I'm like I don't
care if that's her past or not 50 guys
have been up in that I
okay if you want to play around fine but
yeah you know you know to have my kid
then pop out of you too I mean I don't
know no she's been you know she's been
with 50 guys she's been with you know 50
different uh she's got 50 different
pieces of luggage with her you know from
that yeah from that past going back you
don't want to deal with that hell no I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out